guy is in Texas hey sky welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hey Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up well my
wife and I are just cleared baby step
three
and we're prepping for four or five and
six but also purchasing our first home
and we were kind of wondering it's a
hundred percent down plan was good for
us or what you would say about that well
I always love yeah for sure
it's all I do yeah so how much do you
guys make a year we're a single income
family of 97 thousand okay and how much
of that could you save towards a house a
year
mmm mm a month so 24 24 $25,000 a year
okay and what price range of home would
you want to buy about 250 okay well that
would take 10 years 25 million to 250
right yes right so like we currently
have on 32 she's 31 they currently have
74,000 in retirement and we'd be doing
would be maintaining four five and six
simultaneously but we just want to make
sure that you know what part it's
actually Alice okay well how old are you
31 young couple nope no kids - two kids
okay all right well one option is to not
buy ten fifty thousand dollar house the
first one by a cheaper when the first
one it's true and then keep saving you
can you buy a house quicker you know I
mean if you bought up one hundred and
something thousand dollar house and you
saved a little bit more if you save
thirty thousand dollars a year you could
do a hundred thousand three years one
hundred and thirty thousand and four
years you know that's that kind of thing
so just kind of back your goals in and
look at that and say how quick can we do
it and then you can set whether you want
to do that or whether you want to do the
you know as much down as possible and
put it on 15-year fixed where the
payments no more than a fourth year
take-home pay and then turn and pay it
off as fast as possible right so you can
you could go either route I don't yell
at people for either one of those routes
I don't borrow money for
anything ever of course I will never go
back and so that's you know but but the
home is the one thing I just don't yell
at people about everything else you
should just save up and pay for it's
silly not just silly so but but the
house you can go either direction I
would challenge it if you were going to
do the hundred percent down plan to
temporarily put off retirement and just
do baby step 3b and I would challenge
you tighten that budget even tighter and
let's say how crazy can we go how fast
can we save I mean could we save fifty
thousand it would do double that and if
you did that for three years you'd have
a hundred fifty thousand dollar house
and two years later you could move three
years later you move again by two
hundred fifty three hundred thousand
dollar house because you have no house
payment then no rent for that other
section once you've bought the first
place that's it that's a way to kind of
step into it but but if you were gonna
if you're gonna do that I would turn up
the heat and be very very very focused
and very intense on that goal and that's
how Sharon I have done it on things we
get ready to do we just go boom that's
it we're not do anything else completely
focus on that until we get that done